hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant attacking game from round
eight of the melt water champions
chester finals uh it's levon arenan vs
magnus carlsen and the magnus already
won the
champions chess tour uh he doesn't need
to finish the tournament no one can
catch up to him but this tournament is
still um going on and this is another
game that we're going to show story
about not finishing the match magnus had
against uh taymor rajabov
won that match very nicely
but we had some grape picking action
with the family so of course that could
not be
avoided or postponed no one should ever
avoid that
uh so that being said uh let's check out
this game so the one with the white
pieces opens with e4 uh this is the the
first game of their match we have knight
to c6 by magnus going for the names of
each defense and now d4 we have d5 now
sort of the scandinavian variation
of the names of each and it's pretty
much the same thing if captures captures
now black goes after the d4 pawn white
will defend it and then black will
probably execute e5 because why not now
you if it's allowed you should do it
knight for example c3 bishop b4 and the
game continues this is okay for for both
players but here
we have e5 advancing the pawn and before
i continue this i would just like to
address one thing uh from time to time i
get some questions in the comment
section about why not introducing the
evaluation bar into my videos the
problem is
you think that this would give you a
clearer
uh
idea of what's happening on the board
but that could not be further from the
truth the thing is when you uh
put any position uh to an engine the
engine will say okay white is better
0.79
let's say uh at the depth uh 17. and
then you allow the engine to crunch the
numbers a bit further then you get depth
18 then depth 19 then depth 20. and uh
with every depth the evaluation changes
and then we would have to wait a very
long time uh during the video to
for you guys to see what the actual
evaluation was and sometimes if the
position is complicated and there's
really a lot to consider i even allow
the engine to crunch the numbers to
maybe even depth 40 maybe even beyond
but it's uh only for certain positions
and it would take too much time during
the video to allow the the engine to do
this so i do it before the video or if
the tournament is happening then i do it
during the game and then i just present
it to you guys without you guys having
to wait for the actual evaluation and if
it's a really big tournament like the
champions chester here then uh for
example if magnus is playing then the
norwegian supercomputer cese also is
evaluating all the games i don't know at
what depth but i think it's at least the
depth 50 or beyond which is unreachable
to to our engines at least um if you
know we don't want to spend uh
like half an hour evaluating a position
so i also use uh cesis um assessment of
the position while while uh
showing these games to you guys and um
uh just something i wanted to address it
would be it would consume simply too
much time to have the evaluation bar on
the video and it would never be correct
like we go through the moves during
these presentations too fast and the
engine would never uh be able to give
you a clear prediction of what's
actually happening on the board so i use
all of this and then just you know
package it nicely and then present it to
you guys without you guys having to wait
that's that's basically why i'm not
using an evaluation bar during my videos
so that being said uh let's check out
the game uh or rather continue checking
out the game so e5
levon goes for the advanced variation
and now bishop to f5 you want to play e6
you don't want your bishop closed inside
of your pawn chain you want to play e6
and then maybe this bishop comes to g6
at some point or white will probably
develop the bishop to d3 and then we can
trade it here by either capturing or
we're going to allow white to capture
our bishop all depending on what is
played and you could go for some sort of
a bayonet attack as it seems like a
similar position but in this position it
doesn't really work it's been played a
few times without much success so c3
just strengthening the center here and
now e6 magnus closes the chain bishop to
d3 and now of course knight g to e7 now
we want to white the character here and
then we get a beautiful outpost for our
knight on f5 we have knight to e2 by
magnus sorry about lebron
and magnus place h5 and this is a very
useful move like we said this bishop has
to capture on f5 at some point we're
going to bring our knight to f5 and we
don't want to allow whites to be able to
dislodge this knight by playing a move
like g4 so bishop to g5 you played h5
you can no longer play h6 so bishop to
g5 makes sense and magnus on pins queen
to d7 and now uh the the position has
been reached before bishop captures on
f5 is a known move but levon plays h4
and it is now only as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game and i would
just like to mention that uh levon uh
played h4 in many positions even before
alpha zero made it cool so he is one of
the pioneers of the of the h4 idea in
general
uh we have bishop captures on d3 queen
captures on d3 and not knight to f5 and
now this knight is beautifully placed um
you will not you you will have a lot of
problems dislodging it from there knight
to d2 by lavon and now bishop to e7
offering a trade of bishops and levon
trades captures captures of course you
capture with the knight you want to make
room for your sea pawn but it's still
unclear whether magnus will castle king
side or queen side uh levon's king's
still in the center of the board so
they're both still uh waiting to see
what the other guy will do knights to f3
now with the uh e pawn uh here guarding
against f6 maybe the knight can even be
put to g5 at some point we have queen
side castles by magnus uh and now comes
a4 levon wants to push push those spawns
and uh well not like that obviously and
start attacking carlson's queen side and
now knight the g6 magnus will of course
do the exact opposite and he will attack
levon's king side we have g3
strengthening the pawn here and now we
have f6 uh we've uh
put all of our pieces where they need to
be and now it's time to bust open the
center and try and use the df file for
for some attacks here so b4 levon has
seen too many of my videos not to know
that b4 is always the correct
idea we've kinked a b8 a nice
prophylactic move by magnus and now uh
castle's king side we have rook h2f8 now
preparing to uh put some uh heavy pieces
on the f file and the king to h2 uh by
lavon adding uh more defense to
these pawns at at some point magnus
could really start sacrificing those
knights so queen to f7 you want to
capture here and then the position will
open up and now knight eat the g1 seems
like a passive square for the knight but
the the knight and queen are doing a
wonderful job guarding
white's king side we have knight to h6
magnus now bringing the knight to g4 and
rook eight to e1 adding another defender
to the pawn because this pawn uh will be
a weak pawn so knights to g4 with check
king to g2 and now f captures an e5 we
have d captures on e5 luckily our pawn
is nicely protected here even though
both of the knights are attacking it and
now magnus says all right we need
to somehow increase the pressure but
it's very hard we can't really do
anything on the f file uh it's very
unlikely that this rook can come to f5
and then put even more pressure
along the f file so let's play queen to
e8 put some pressure on the a4 pawn but
we're really going for rook to f5 adding
another attacker to the e5 pawn so how
will levon defend this levon of course
not um interested in defending the a4
pawn he just plays knights the h3 now
with the queen leaving this f file we
can allow
this knight to move and now this knight
is coming to g5 and that will put a lot
of pressure on the e6 pawn magnus
continues with his plan he plays rook to
f5 now the e5 pawn is attacked three
times but now knight h to g5 and uh it's
not really upon sacrifice as you'll see
magnus grabs the pawn there's really
nothing better knight six captures on e5
knight captures we have knight captures
on e5 and now comes queen to d4 now with
a double attack on the knight here but
also if the knight moves you can go
after that g7 pawn and also uh once the
knight moves you will have a very nice
attack on the e6 pawn so levon magnus
plays the absolute best idea knights to
c6 for the moment the queen is attacked
so you can't go after this spawn but you
could could go after queen to g7 but
this is a an attacking game uh kings
have castled on opposite sides of the
board so lavon not too crazy about
opening up the g file for for magnus's
pieces to use just yet he moves the
queen back queen to d3 and now okay you
have to do something about this pawn
being attacked so that magnus just
defends it rook to f6 defends the pawn
and now b5 attacks the knight and asks
magnus what do you do with this knight
you can't go here the rook covers that
you can't go here otherwise we just pick
up the
the pawn
and well other than that there really
are no good squares so you have to go to
a5 it's an ugly square and for the
moment magnus is definitely down a piece
until this knight rejoins the game and
only now a queen to h7 uh putting
pressure on g7 also h5 is threatened if
this queen ever moves from e8 and now uh
how how do you defend this well magnus
has a few things to consider but if you
if you guarded the pawn here you could
already run into a lot of trouble for
example knight captures on e6 and after
you capture let's say rook captures
queen captures and queen h8 it's a game
over there's really nothing for for
black to do you have to give up the rook
just to be able to block checkmate with
the queen and of course the rook against
knight end game is completely winning so
instead after queen to h7 magnus
continues in a very principled manner he
pushes e5 it's a
very dangerous pawn so why not continue
advancing it and now only now levon
captures and g7 puts pressure on the
rook we have rook to f5 and now queen to
h7 continues harassing carlson's rook
and now magnus goes all the way back
rook to f8 uh if rook to f6 we probably
see a draw here but you you never know
there would it be a three-fold
repetition or not magnus goes back rook
to f8 uh and now comes f4 this is what
levon wanted now uh you will continue
advancing the pawn because the e pawn is
pinned you cannot capture and this way
levon creates a beautiful pass pawn so
e4 magnus also creates a pass pawn and
f5 now we have queen to e5 not worried
about knight to e6 because for the
moment it doesn't really do all that
much if 96 rook g8 and you have you
could have some problems here uh you'd
probably have to go back knight to g5 so
it's just wasting a move levon advances
the pawn all the way to f6 now takes
away the
e7 square from the black queen
because
aside from knight to the e6 you could
also try knight to f7 seems like it's
winning but queen to a7 and you don't
have even that now the knight can't
really move so by playing f6 you take
away the e7 square from carlson's queen
and now what can magnus play
well if you go after the pawn with rook
captures on f6 then you get knight f7
but now queen to e7 is impossible
because we just captured the rook and
after queen captures now we pick up the
knight queen captures uh and just queen
captures on h5 of course we're not
completely winning we're up the exchange
and we even though black has some points
here in the center it's really not that
relevant
so uh instead after this uh f6 move we
have queen captures on c3 by magnus now
he has two connected past pawns and well
the white king is somewhat vulnerable
but levon says not a problem i'm just
going to push my pawn to f7 and now how
do you how do you defend this
magnus says
alright i have to bring this knight into
the game uh we're not winning this game
being down a piece and now knight's the
e6 going after the rooks uh and there
really isn't all that much uh for magnus
to do now he has to continue attacking
queen to d to check king to h3 and now
knight to e5 are going for knights to f3
uh this does come with a sort of a rook
sacrifice because the rook cannot be
captured it's it's really an exchange
sacrifice but magnus doesn't even bother
to capture this he just plays knight to
f3 he threatens checkmate on h2 we've
reached the position from the thumbnail
hopefully uh and now
there is one move that wins the game for
lavonne so feel free to pause the video
here and win this game for levon while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well almost unspottable move because who
would play such a thing and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
not rook captures an f3 it's queen
captures an h5 that's the good stuff uh
the problem with rook captures on f3 yes
there is no checkmate anymore but after
queen captures on e1 your rook is still
hanging and checkmate is still being
threatened the king will not be able to
go to g4 and now there really isn't all
that much if knight d7 check hoping for
captures and bringing another queen into
the game we just move the king and now
you're gonna have to block with rook f2
but we just capture it queen captures
and after queen g8 it's uh it's a draw
there's nothing either player can do
here we would probably see a nice
repetition here or something so instead
uh levon played queen captures on h5 but
not right away he first played knight at
d7 check he wants to check if magnus uh
you know wants to blunder the game on
the spot uh magnus decides against it he
just moves the king king to e8 and now
queen captures an e5 and this is just
beautiful it doesn't matter if queen h2
check is played king g4 and there is no
way to keep attacking the white king the
king is just extremely safe here even
though if it's on g4 so after queen
captures on h5 knight captures an e1 was
played but now levon just plays f8 queen
brings another queen into the game and
he was in this position and move 40 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you could still continue harassing the
black king for example queen g2 check
king g4 queen e to check you're gonna
play king g5 queen e3 check king to g6
you can even play queen characters and
g3 check but after king h7 there is
nothing more uh that you can play here
and whatever you play you're getting
checkmated so there's no no no hope for
for uh
black here whatsoever
uh so yeah really interesting they could
have played it up to here just you know
for the fun of it uh for the white king
being on h7 but i guess no no one was
interested uh so after f8 queen uh on
move 40 it was in this position that
magnus carlsen resigned in the game so
game two and three were again a draw and
then levon won a game in the game one
again in game four with the black pieces
magnus was not able to force anything
with white and levon wins this uh match
so uh even though magnus won the male
twitter champions chester in general uh
he did uh
run into some problems uh
even in last round against taymor rajab
and now against levon arunan but today
is the match that everyone is looking
forward to and that of course it's uh
magnus
versus wesley so so we're gonna check
out that one as well
uh so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank uh aaron
anders uh garrett meyers mark adrian
fosse micah kennedy and constantinos
from pedrakis for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i have really
appreciated as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day